>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR
FINAL EXAM WE DETERMINE
WHICH ONES OF OUR FOX NEWS
REGULARS HAS BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE NEWS.
YOU WOULD ASSUME ALL OF
THEM.
WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND OUT.
WITH US IS GRIFF JENKINS.
HE HAS WON A NUMBER OF TIMES
IN A ROW.
LATEST CHALLENGER KATE
PAVLICH.
AS YOU KNOW, KATIE, YOUR
COMPETITOR HAS WON FOUR
TIMES IN A ROW.
EACH TIME HE HAS BEEN
WEARING A SLING FOR HIS
INJURED ARM WHICH HE
DESTROYED ON "FOX & FRIENDS
WEEKEND."
NOW HE IS OUT OF THE SLING.
WHICH MAKES HIM EVEN FASTER.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FIRST TIME WE WILL SEE HOW
IT GOES.
GRIFF GRIFF I NEED BOTH ARMS
TO BEAT KATIE.
>> Tucker: SHE IS VERY GOOD.
HANDS ON BUZZERS.
I ASK THE QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST PERSON WHO BUZZES
IN GETS TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL I
HAVE COMPLETED THE QUESTION
BEFORE BUZZING IN.
EACH CORRECT ANSWER GETS YOU
ONE POINT.
EACH INCORRECT ANSWER
SUBTRACTS A POINT FROM YOUR
TOTAL, BEST OF FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> READY.
>> Tucker: OUTSTANDING,
QUESTION ONE.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES JUST TOLD REPORTERS
IS HE CONSIDERING A PARDON
NOT ONLY FOR FORMER ILLINOIS
GOVERNOR ROD BLOG BUT ALSO
FOR WHICH DOMESTIC GODDESS?
KATIE PAVLICH?
>> MARTHA STEWART.
>> Tucker: IS IT MARTHA
STEWART?
>> A PARDON NOW FOR MARTHA
STEWART.
STUART, YOU'LL REMEMBER, WAS
CONVICTED BACK IN 2004 OF
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE AND
LYING TO THE GOVERNMENT
ABOUT WHY SHE UNLEWDED STOCK
JUST BEFORE THE PRICE
PLUMMETED.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS SHE,
QUOTE:  USED TO BE ONE OF MY
BIGGEST FANS.
>> Tucker: MARTHA STEWART
NOT ONLY A GENIUS.
>> DOWN HILL FROM HERE.
>> Tucker: QUESTION TWO.
KATIE IS IN THE LEAD.
MULTIPLE CHOICE QUESTION.
FRANCE, THE COUNTRY, JUST
DISCOVERED ITS OWN VERSION
OF SPIDERMAN.
A MAN FROM MALI, THE COUNTRY
OF MALI SCALED THE FRONT OF
AN APARTMENT BUILDING TO
SAVE A TODDLER FROM FALLING
OFF THE BALCONY.
THAT MAN HAS BEEN OFFERED
THAT YOU JOB FOR REWARD FOR
HEROISM IS THAT JOB A HIGH
RISE WINDOW WASHER A FIREMAN
OR C A CIRCUS ACROBAT?
GRIFF JENKINS?
>> FIREMAN.
>> Tucker: AS WE SAY IN OUR
COUNTRY FIREFIGHTER.
IS IT FIREMAN.
>> 22-YEAR-OLD BEING CALLED
A REAL LIFE FIREMAN,
SWINGING ONE BALCONY TO
ANOTHER REACHING THE CHILD
IN LESS THAN 30 SECONDS.
HE HAS ALSO BEEN GIVEN A JOB
AS A FIREMAN.
>> GOOD FOR HIM.
>> Tucker: OUTSTANDING THAT
WAS COMPELLING.
VERY GOOD I'M NOT UP ON THE
NEWS 1 TO 1.
QUESTION 3.
IN BROCK WORTH EDGE GLAMMED
THIS WEEK CITIZENS COMPETED
IN UNUSUAL.
HURLED THEMSELF DOWN A STEEP
HILL.
A RACE TO CATCH A ROLLING
PIECE OF WHAT TYPE OF FOOD?
GRIFF JENKINS?
>> CHEESE.
>> Tucker: CHEESE?
>> Tucker: TO THE TAPE WE
GO.
>> THESE PEOPLE CHASE CHEESE
DOWN A HILL.
THE CHEESE IS ROLLING DOWN
AT 70 MILES PER HOUR.
THERE IS THE WINNER.
AND HE DIDN'T EVEN WIN ANY
MONEY.
HE JUST WON THE CHEESE.
>> HE JUST GOT CHEESE.
>> WELL WORTH IT.
>> Tucker: FOX NEWS
REPORTER.
>> I WAS A DOMESTIC
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
INTERNATIONAL BUSINESS.
YOU WERE TOLD THERE WAS NO
FOREIGN POLICY ON THE EXAM.
CHEATED.
SO, 2 TO 1.
QUESTION 4.
IN THE AGE OF EMAIL, THE
UNITED STATES POSTAL SERVICE
IS TRYING SOMETHING NEW IN
ORDER TO ATTRACT BUSINESS.
THIS SUMMER THE POSTAL
SERVICE WILL INTRODUCE A
SCRATCH AND SNIFF WHAT?
POSTAL SERVICE KATIE
PAVLICH?
>> STAMP.
>> Tucker: WHAT ELSE COULD
IT BE?
I DON'T KNOW.
LET'S ROLL THE TAPE.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER
SCRATCH AND SNIFF STAMPS
WILL BE AVAILABLE.
>> I JUST GUESSED.
>> YOU CAN SEE DELICIOUS,
SMELL SWEET AND DELICIOUS
LIKE SUMMER.
>> SMELL IT BEFORE IT GOES
IN THE MAIL WITH ALL THE
OTHER MAIL.
>> Tucker: THAT CLIP WAS
FROM GMA.
FOX NEWS CAN CONFIRM IT IS A
SCRATCH AND SNIFF STAMP SO
YOU ARE RIGHT.
NOW WE ARE 2 TO 2.
SUDDEN DEATH.
GRIFF JENKINS ALWAYS FINDS
HIMSELF IN THIS PLACE AND
BRINGS IT RIGHT TO THE END.
HERE IS THE FINAL QUESTION.
WHICH TENNESSEE UNITED
STATES SENATOR WAS JUST
BOOED BY A HOMETOWN CROWD
WHEN THE PRESIDENT CALLED
OUT HIS NAME AT A RALLY IN
NASHVILLE?
KATIE PAVLICH.
>> SENATOR BOB CORKER.
>> Tucker: SENATOR BOB
CORKER.
HOLD ON.
THIS WILL DECIDE THE OUTCOME
OF TONIGHT'S FINAL EXAM.
ROLL THE TAPE, PLEASE.
>> SENATOR BOB CORKER.
[CROWD BOOS]
>> Tucker: AND THE REIGN WAS
ENDED.
KATIE PAVLICH I CANNOT
BELIEVE YOU DETHRONED GRIFF
JENKINS.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
I TOOK THE SLING OFF.
I WAS RED I DIDN'T KNEW I
WAS AGAINST A FIERCE
COMPETITOR.
>> Tucker: ONE OF THOSE
PARADOXES LIKE ON THE
BEATITUDES.
YOU ARE NOT DISABLED,
WEAKER.
>> I SHOULD POINT OUT, TOO,
A BOY FROM TENNESSEE BEAT
FROM A GORGEOUS WOMAN FROM
ARIZONA IT'S JUST POETIC
JUSTICE.
>> Tucker: CONGRATULATIONS
TO YOU.
>> THANK YOU SOME.
>> Tucker: YOU WIN OUR ERIC
WEMPLE MUG.
THERE IS HIS PICTURE.
CAN YOU DRINK YOUR COFFEE
FROM IT.
>> Tucker: GRIFF JENKINS,
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> CHEERS.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU BACK FOR
THE ROUNDING OF CHAMPIONS.
>> SOUNDS GOOD.